when you think of a burger what you need
is a great sauce and a light
smoky barbecue goes hand in glove with a
great burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic
nice hot pan tablespoon of olive oil
onions and garlic into the pan
nice seasoning salt and pepper now the
secret of a good barbecue sauce
is that really important caramelization
to begin with
a nice tablespoon of brown sugar it
darkens
the onions but it really starts to sort
of give that nice syrupy
body to the sauce and put a little bit
of heat in there now
a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices you've got to cook them out
and almost sort of
burn off that rawness especially with a
smoked paprika
that's exactly where i want it to go
onions and garlic
beautifully caramelized
cider vinegar in reduce that down
now i've got a fantastic smoky base to
complete the sauce
i'm making my life really easy and
adding pre-made worcester sauce
and tomato ketchup cook that out for two
to three minutes
now depending on how thick you like the
barbecue sauce
that determines how long you cook it out
for i don't want it to be too
runny but i don't want it too thick
either that's the
consistency we're looking for
lovely turn down the gas
charger seasoning
now take that out it's the kind of sauce
that i like to have sort of
bottled up in the fridge it's great for
sandwiches
but goes brilliantly well with these
sliders homemade
smoky barbecue sauce
[Music]
give the pan a little wipe now start the
mix for the sliders
to give my mix a really interesting
flavor and texture i'm gonna be using
unsmoked back bacon
i travel all over the world
and i spend a lot of time in the states
they know how to make a great slider
pork sliders beef sliders chicken
sliders
and it's almost like a way of having a
burger
but on a much smaller miniature level
a little teaspoon of olive oil i want
that bacon to get really nice and crispy
bacon in this just gives the really nice
sort of
chunky delicious mix i want texture
and pork is perfect for slider
[Music]
and choppy shallot
[Music]
shallots are a lot sweeter than your
normal white onion
fine fine fine and in
[Music]
now that bacon's getting really nice and
crispy i want a bit of heat in there
a little teaspoon of smoked paprika in
there
when you see these sliders in the states
for one portion there's like
four or five of them little mini one
biters
incredible now take your pork
just open up and give that a really nice
seasoning
so important you can't season a slider
after you've cooked it it's impossible
so season it nicely
bake it now that's nice and crispy just
take
a little touch kitchen roll and just
drain that off there
nice pat that nice and dry
i want all that nice sort of crispiness
in there beautiful mix all that
in take a nice ball
and sort of roll it
the size of a golf ball get it nice
and round first and then three fingers
just pat that down don't flatten them
too thin otherwise they overcook and
they go
sort of dry
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big
good
get the pan nice and hot tablespoon of
olive oil
when a slider is literally that thick
about an inch thick
we're going gonna take two and a half to
three minutes to each side in
turn them over lovely
once you've turned them tilt the pan and
just spoon
all that juice back into them keep my
mouth watering now
very easy to dry the pork out so just
feeling it now your fingers is
nice and firm it's a little touch of
springiness
in the center i'm happy with those
add your cheese now so it gets nicely
melted
i'm using wedgies or smoked cheddar
and it has that nice sort of soury smoky
creaminess
to the slider finally shredded baby gem
lettuce
just take those buns make sure they're
sliced
nice and evenly take your lettuce
be quite generous with the lettuce just
a nice thin slice
of tomato take your burgers
you see that cheese you feed melted
your bbq sauce
place the top on and that is my version
the slider that is small dynamic but
packed
full of flavour i'll take that over a
hamburger any day
[Music]
first off get that pan really nice and
hot these are
sirloin steaks sear it in the pan with
all that fat on
i'll add flavor salt and pepper
couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan nice and hot hold up the steak
and lay it in always lay away give the
pan a
little shake and it stops the steak from
sticking we're looking for color
and if it sticks it's gonna burn
[Music]
while the steaks are cooking i can get
on with my super quick marinade
now two tablespoons of
misood paste that's a fermented soybean
that gives a really nice sort of rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar a couple of
tablespoons rice wine
that gives it a really nice vinegary
kick a couple of tablespoons
of olive oil salt and pepper
i'm looking for a nice sort of thick
rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks
sort the pan and to give the steak
a little base all we're doing every time
is just adding more and more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back
and really melt all that fat down
offer the gas take them out
just take your knife it's all that fat
there
just slice that off i don't want any of
that
now in to the marinade
[Music]
beautiful tacos are one of mexico's most
popular street foods they've been made
from
beef pork chicken or fish and are loaded
up with amazing sauces
and spices now i want something sort of
pickly
cabbage these are um chinese cabbages
slice it
in half
and look at it really crisp and really
tasty
we're gonna slice that into quarters and
then
just shred it and take your time
you think of cabbage hair and you think
of sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but at a taco you want freshness a
little season
chili flakes they sort of discreetly
give it a little bit of heat a little
touch
of rice wine vinegar if you haven't got
that
fresh lemon juice a small drop of
toasted sesame seed oil give that
a really good mix now i need something
to sort of
bring it together we take some wasabi
paste very hot very spicy a sort of
thumbnail size
i'm gonna mix and that couple of
tablespoons
of mayonnaise and give that a really
good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them and then shape
them
actually place it on
the gas ring use some tongs
so it's not to burn yourself you can
also toast your tacos in a frying pan
from there i'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin literally 30 seconds
as it cools down the great thing about
serving tacos is
people can fill them themselves just the
way they want them
cabbage just squeeze out wet marinade
a nice rustic little mountain
mayonnaise on wait you see
how soft and delicious and almost sort
of
melting in the mouth texture we've got
on this amazing sirloin
it's look at that really nice sear
around the outside
it's just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my crispy shell back of
the spoon
with the wasabi mayonnaise inside
taco and just sprinkle that delicious
pickled cabbage and then just
start lining my taco three or four
slices
touch more on my spicy
layer and that is how i'd make
the perfect attacker
[Music]
just open up and drain
the tuna into a sieve just lightly flake
that
don't press it too hard otherwise you'll
dry out the tuna
now these are water chestnuts just slice
them
nice and thin you can buy them anywhere
any supermarket
chestnuts and fresh ginger
get rid of that rough skin on the
outside
by grating the ginger you get to get all
that really nice
sort of juice in
take your spring onions and just slice
on an angle i like the texture of the
water chestnut
with a spring onion or touch of fresh
coriander
lovely next remove the seeds from a
chili to reduce its heat without losing
any flavor
and finely chop chilies
in kaffir lime leaves roll them up
nice and tight run your knife down the
center
once and just chop
and that makes the fish cake nice and
fragrant
touch of salt a touch of pepper
fish sauce just lightly season
the tuna to bind all those wonderful
ingredients
two whole eggs
and give that a nice little whisk
and then add your eggs
get your hands in there and start mixing
get the mixture roll it and hand the
hand
into the palm pat them down nicely
to cook add a little ground oil to a hot
pan
at the face of a clock i'm going to go
from 12 all the way around
first one in these fish cakes only take
a few minutes to cook
so keeping track of the order they go in
the pan means you know which one to turn
first
[Music]
to the pad a nice gentle little shake
make sure that nothing's sticking to the
bottom
spatula two fingers on top turn them
over
beautiful that crackling noise is
something you always want because
the tune's already cooked so we're just
lightly frying them we get a nice
crisp outside and gently take them out
smell incredible
let them sit there we're gonna make a
really nice delicious simple dipping
sauce
start off a little pinch of sugar fish
sauce
two tablespoons that gives it the
saltiness
one tablespoon of rice wine vinegar
and some fresh lime juice squeeze all
that lime in there
your fresh coriander lots of coriander
and then give that
a little mix and then you have
the most amazing spicy tuna fish cakes
who would have thought
something as delicious as that can come
out of a can a simple supper in minutes
that's so mouth-wateringly easy and
delicious
you're guaranteed to cook it again and
again
you